all right hello everybody
welcome to games of the week i'm
grandmaster steven zerk
for this week i'm gonna be covering
three very nice wins
by nepo as black in the currently
running magnus carlson invitational
so firstly from the qualifiers for the
prelims
and then some very nice wins as black
from the quarterfinal and semi-final as
well
so spoilers there
so this first game again it's from the
preliminaries
from the round robin and in this game
nepo was black against anishigiri
and as we're going to see nepal wins as
black or has potential to win his black
for a couple reasons
as we're going to see he plays some very
volatile openings
in this first game he plays the time in
off sicilian
and you know he's quite fond of
especially in rapid but even classical
time controls he's fond of openings that
are much more double-edged and uneven
you know the french is black as we're
going to see some sharp lines of the
vienna is black
all of these lines give white a lot of
chance to go wrong
and while it's less stream extreme and
rapid even in rapid in this tournament
right you're going to see a good number
of
pretty symmetrical italians and berlins
these openings are much more solid for
black they introduce much less risk into
the black position
which is the more standard way to play
at top level now
but at the same time they give white
much less chance to go wrong too
black doesn't so much seek to create
direct problems for white in these lines
because we're going to see part of the
reason especially when he's
when he's what's the phrase when he's in
form or when his opponent is struggling
at all
things can be very difficult for nepo's
opponent even when he's playing black
he said in this game he goes for the
timing off
in this position there are many ways
white can respond
two of the classic ways are to play
bishop e3
and after queen c7 white can play queen
d2
which leads to a very sharp double-edged
attack with queen side castling f3 g4
this english attack or white can play
the currently trendy queen f3
which also enables quick queen side
castling and can often enable queen g3
which is usually a trade white's happy
to make usually these end games with h6
g3 are good for white
so those are two trendy ways out of many
possible ways for white to respond to
the timing off
in this game geary goes for a less
common but still popular option
he takes on c6 immediately
and after b takes the standard idea is
that even though black has an extra
center pawn now thanks to this capture
the standard way for white to play is
just to continue developing
and just say i'm going to have good
pressure thanks to my good development
lead in spite of your strong center i
can put pressure on it very quickly
while you're catching up in development
in this game though geary responds to
what is that top level or less common
opening choice the timing off
with a bit of an unusual line of his own
he plays this very rare move queen d3
and so again not something you see very
often
the idea is like in the other line i
mentioned the queen f3 lines
the idea is to go to g3 and the queen on
g3 serves a couple purposes
d5 queen g3 one thing and this is
something french players will know as
well
this green on the g file can actually be
very annoying for black's development
this pawn on g7 can't just be given up
that means this f8 bishop is tied down
and that actually means that while this
situation remains
it's awkward for black to actually solve
this problem there isn't a great way
queen f6 can run into e5 ideas for
instance or bishop d3 and e5
g6 which black sometimes plays in the
french can lead to a lot of weaknesses
and apart from that there's not really a
great way for black to handle this pawn
what nepo actually does is thematic in
the timing off first he plays d4
he uses this extra central control to
kick white's knight back
the knight goes to b1 looks a little
weird but
there's not really a great option if the
knight goes to a4 this is a real tragedy
just queen a5 check
the knight goes to e2 it's interfering
with white's bishop
if the knight goes to d1 it has no
squares so the knight heads to b1
you see this in some other openings as
well because of d4 c4 even
is a very promising square for the
knight or perhaps f3
but at the same time you can see that
white's not really
gunning for a development advantage
either and it's kind of a strange
position
where eight and a half moves into the
game and the only piece developed is the
white queen
but okay that's that's modern chess it's
very concrete
and funnily enough to make it even more
extreme nepo's ninth move doesn't
develop at all he plays h5
this is not something to be imitated
lightly right you're not developing
you're opening up your own king side
where your king is likely to go
but at the same time it's concretely
actually a pretty annoying move for
white
the idea is pretty simple if white does
something like knight d2 or develops the
bishop with bishop c4
black has h4 queen g4 knight f6
and not only maybe black can play h3
weakening light's king side
but black is also kicking this queen out
kicking the queen off the g pawn
which enables him to develop
so this is actually pretty annoying now
that this white queen has moved to g3
and h5 again don't imitate it lightly
make sure you know what you're doing and
you don't just get steamrolled by an
attack but h5 against this queen is
very typical in the time and off and
actually this h4s
idea is so annoying that geary as white
often does
yuri responds with h4 himself
but the upside to this right the queen's
still on g3
but the upside to this is we've gotten
some weak squares black can use
especially g4
so after knight f6 if white goes bishop
d3 now for example
now black can play knight g4
by covering these threats without h3
this knight's kind of annoying to get
rid of
if white tries f3 black goes bishop d6
and you can see white can't really
maintain the threat on the knight
and cover his queen if white tries
bishop f4 then he
black takes the queen off the g file and
plays knight e3
and you can see this isn't the end of
the world for white but it certainly
doesn't look pretty and certainly black
is not unhappy with this position
so if you understand the ideas behind h5
this move has a lot of potential
to help black develop his position
so after knight f6 instead of bishop d3
theory goes e5
now after knight g4 with f3
there was no bishop d6 but nepo simply
goes knight e4
and this draws the queen off the g file
because it has no squares
queen f4 and bishop b4
and as you can kind of see right this is
stylistically
very much the opposite of a berlin the
pawn structure is very unusual the
position is very volatile in general
and nepo plays a l plays into a lot of
volatile middle games
where a single mistake from either side
can
cost the game can be catastrophic and
not only that but these positions are
very tricky to play correctly
so both players will tend to make more
mistakes than
in a lot of what i'll call meta openings
at top level
here he goes knight d2 ends up trading
both pieces
right if black if black doesn't trade
you can lose some time
not that it's necessarily impossible but
black's playing very quickly to get the
pieces out
and here nepo does make a bit of a slip
plays queen d5
so it looks somewhat natural at
activating the queen
but this follows a vowel of something i
talked about before
when black plays h5 it creates this
outpost for white on g5
which is something that white can use to
great effect i myself have won a couple
games against the timing off by using
this outpost for various pieces
and here geary could have used it too
queen g5 is actually pretty annoying for
black
and the idea is suddenly
thanks to this h5 move this kingside
situation is tough to stabilize
right castling runs into the h5 pawn
hanging or even to just direct checkmate
ideas after bishop d3 and g6 just
makes the whole dark square complex here
horrifically weak and white can even
look at bishop d3 followed by sacking on
g6
or castling queenside and playing g4
what i mean this looks like
this looks like a dragon where black has
no dark squared bishop and does advance
the pawns for some reason
so there's a lot of risk on the king
side here for black and this is what
white should have gone for this is what
gary should have played
yuri plays a move f4 that's positionally
sounder
now queen g5 so king f8
now kf8 is absolutely an idea black can
throw in this check too
to cause white to have trouble castling
but it's still very good for white
geary instead plays f4 again
positionally very sound
strong dark squared pawns to go with the
light squared bishop
but at the same time he's not directly
challenging these squares
and so this means that white's attack
white's pressure over here on the king
side is going to come a little more
slowly
so nippo develops his bishop
there's various ways somewhat different
ways both sides can develop here
but he gets the bishop out after bishop
f3 goes queen c5
and the big difference here is we're
going to get opposite side castling
again
if you guys watch the last lecture you
know a few things about that
and white's attack is going to strike
more slowly than it could have in some
other lines
that being said after after castle's
rook d8
white still has a pretty good position
black's pods are a little awkward
even though he has some open lines
there's nothing direct
after king b1 black castles kingside
right this is a downside to h5 this move
is actually a huge favor for white
which again counterbalances some of
black's active play here
but black also has direct ideas if white
takes black can look at d3
black can load up on the b file or black
could go for a4 a3 black has a lot of
attacking ideas here too
in this position right both sides have a
lot of play we have a pretty double
edged opposite side castling middle game
all right and these are the kinds of
positions that nepo plays very well
and that are very tough to play right
that really reward
good play because it does not take much
to lose a position like this
so gary goes rook g one
aiming instead of just grabbing the pawn
yuri wants to open a file
would rather play g4 and after h takes
play rook takes
so instead of winning a pawn he actually
wants to get rid of his own pawns
right white would gladly get rid of
these just for the attacking prospects
because those are much more important
here especially since black's doing the
same thing on the queen side
so rook g1 again going for to rook d7
right aiming potentially to double rooks
on one of these files to activate the
other rook
and geary goes g4
so both sides playing very logically
here though here nepo actually slips
black should have played directly with
d3
and just gone for direct action
if white takes black can take and if
white goes queen g2 going for this
g-file play
as we'll see this was a powerful idea
during the game
black can take and take on d1
and the idea is white can't take with
the bishop
because this runs smack into a back rank
mate with bishop d3
and queen c1 white can't take with the
bishop
so the rook is diverted off of g1 and
black gets their own attacks as well
and both sides again still have a lot of
play here still
a lot of complications
so instead instead nepo goes for
rook b8 which is a very logical move
here
right this is where black very often
wants to pressure since the b file is
open it's analogous to white's pressure
on the g file
but as we're going to see concretely
it's just a little too slow
because here geary actually plays king
a1
to get out of this b file pressure at
least the direct pressure
but as it turns out you had a very
strong alternative and g
takes h5
and this move besides opening the g file
which is something white very much wants
to do
it offers the surprisingly useful
benefit that it covers g6
so after queen g2 unlike in some other
lines black has no g6 defense white
simply takes it
and this extra pressure this extra h5
pawn actually proves to be a real hero
right after d3 now takes takes queen g2
we get a similar situation to what i
discussed before
to that line i gave before with the
quick d3 but this time white has this
extra pawn here
h6 g6 h5 is an idea rook back to g1
with g6 impossible as an idea
and things are a little tougher for
black than they need to be
with that said this is all easy to say
right this is easy to say with an engine
after the game
during the game this b file pressure
does look very dangerous and it is
and gary responds by playing king a1
but now now though now it comes time for
d3
and suddenly this is an even better
version of the original d3
because these two moves have been added
which favor black's attack
security takes takes and queen g2
takes on g4
this time if geary takes with the queen
nepal would take on d1 white has to take
with the rook
diverting from the g file and queen b4
and white has very serious problems here
white actually can't hold together the
position
thanks to this extra bab8 rook move
you know b3 at a minimum there's check
and check winning the exchange
dc3 reminds you of e6 in the last
lecture yep exactly you're breaking down
this
these queen side defenses and white
still has more defenses remaining
unlike aliakin black's pawn is not on c3
yet
so the attack's not quite as strong but
it's very very dangerous
so after h takes geary instead plays
bishop takes g4
keeping the queen on some defensive
duties as well
and here again this is rapid nepo goes
for what i would call the most natural
move just goes for a4 intending a3
instead let's say again he should pull
this white rook off the g
file white's attack is still very very
dangerous
and again tactically white has to take
with the rook and then just brought in
his attacking forces something like
bishop c4 may be heading for d5 or a4
again
as it turns out after a4 g replays the
correct rook takes d3
because it's traded on this square
instead it's true that black's bishop
has been improved
but at the same time white's rook is
still on g1
and this proves to be much more
important
so here geary suddenly had a very had a
very nice tactical resource
right he has the potential of discovered
attacks on g7
in the game giri took on e6
again a very natural move to try and use
this mate threat but as we're going to
see concretely it doesn't work out
the best move for white is actually
bishop f5
and you can see right double threat on
g7 and d3
and actually had he played this guri
could have pressed
after queen g1 which is forced and
bishop f5
white can press for the win here so you
can see this game in particular
was very back and forth extremely
double-edged difficult middle game even
in classical let alone in rapid
and so you can kind of see right why
nepo's results are somewhat volatile
and why when he's on point you can see
how dangerous these positions are white
can have so many great games
here though geary did have this on
opportunity instead he took on e6
all right aiming for more direct
attacking play instead of a better end
game
but suddenly so netball plays g6
right covering the mate threat keeping
the queen active if you have to play
something like queen f8 you are indeed
in big trouble because
your own attack all right your own
attack
is getting stopped so he stays active
with g6
geary plays f5 right this was presumably
the point
right white's attack looks and is very
very dangerous queen takes g6 with mate
next move is threatened
as it turns out nepo had read this out a
little better
he plays this very nice move king f8
and suddenly it turns out that despite
appearances white's attack is actually
too slow
there's simply black's going to play a3
a3 creates may threats
and there's no way for white to break
through immediately
and so
in this position yuri actually takes on
g6 right again there's just not
there's really not a good move here the
problem is after taking on g6
nepo takes on e6 and funnily enough
white is once again cursed by his own
pawns
right if this g6 pawn were gone queen g8
king e7 rook g7 would be mate in two
but here the only open file is the f
file
and then so the problem is if sorry if
giri takes it
nepo can block with the bishop and white
simply can't get through quickly enough
why can't breakthrough for this attack
before black makes their own threats
before nepo makes his own threats
so after rook d1 and funnily enough
again there's just there's just no way
through despite what appearances might
suggest g7 king g8
black uses this pawn as a shield after
rook d1 targeting the bishop
but it's not enough now a3 comes and
with it the threats that white simply
can't stop
gary checks on f3 bishop f5 again all
the lines are covered
and technically speaking most tenacious
is to go into an endgame with queen a3
it takes takes but in spite of the
material equality this is hopeless for
white
because all black has to do is advance
the c pawn
c2 white can't take it because there
will be mate
play c2 rook b1 and the game is over
so instead gary plays b3 but this runs a
foul of queen takes e5 check
with mate and here gary resigned
so as we can see a very double edge to
somewhat back and forth game
but a kind of middle game that nepo
loves playing and often plays
where white takes serious risks as well
and a nice win this was one of actually
four black wins
nepo had in the qualifiers which proved
crucial for his
advancing to the knockout and
i highly recommend by the way looking at
the qualifier win against wesley so as
well
another very strong opponent and another
great game with black
now though i'm going to advance to the
brackets
so his quarterfinal match was against
ikaro nakamura
and once again when nakamura opens up
with e4
he plays the time in off sicilian
knight f3 e6
nakamura like giri nakamura goes for a
somewhat unusual line
it goes knight c3 queen c7 which is the
main continuation
and now as i mentioned before there's
various continuations here bishop e3
followed by queen d2 or queen f3
are kind of the modern critical ones
very popular white can also play
somewhat slower with bishop e2
nakamura plays a less common move f4
they're just going for direct central
control but at the same time
potentially leaving white some problems
on this diagonal or leaving white's king
a little more open right it's a much
more committal move
than developing a bishop
yet but continues with typical time and
of ideas
a6 b5 and develops the bishop
it's a very standard setup
why is white not doing a c4 e4 structure
white can also play that way i can go
for a quick c4 before knight c3
black has various ideas like knight f6
followed by bishop b4 after knight c3 to
pressure the e4 pawn
that is also a way white can play
so castle is d6 and all of this is
pretty typical this is a pretty standard
setup for black
not just in the time and off bishop gets
fianchetto here these e6 d6 pawns
control a lot of very important squares
and this setup correspondingly white the
cars
setup is a very standard way for white
to play in the sicilian
this bishop's prepared on this diagonal
this knight heads to b3
when it's pressured on d4 all very
standard sometimes this bishop's on e3
instead
but still very typical position
bishop e7 rookie one white's kind of
completed their setup for the middle
game
why is it white just better with much
more space
so the big reason i would say
one big thing about the sicilian is
black has a very
black has very good square control with
these two pawns
so black has a lot of potential to
explode in the center
play with d5 or sometimes e5 and this
bishop can become very strong
kasparov called the sicilian a coiled
spring
and i think that's a good way to
summarize black's position
it's just playing black in these
positions it's all about finding the
right moment to jump into action
and we're going to see nepo does it
perfectly in this game
so netball plays b4
the most popular move here has just been
the castle
again just kind of completing black
setup but b4 is playable as well
and here nakamura makes the first slip
funnily enough
nakamura had this exact position as
white back in 2003
you know back when he was a mere 25 50
or so
and in that game he actually played the
correct move which is knight a4
the knight might look a little funny
here but
the idea is actually somewhat reactive
when black goes d5
later on the knight can take the c5
square
or even in some lines with bishop e3 the
b6 square can be very useful
the knight looks a little funny here and
that's presumably why he didn't play
knight a4 in this game
it looks a little risky there even
because it can be targeted but
concretely as we're going to see
the movie plays instead knight d1 is
just too passive
it gives black a free hand on the queen
side and it also enables a5 a4 which is
another very useful reason to have the
knight on a4 yourself
this move kind of gives black a free
hand for queen side play
so nepo continues with a5
and nakamura makes another
another very um reasonable looking move
that turns out to be an error
it goes to knight f2 right logical
follow-up getting this knight to a more
useful square
potentially heading here to trade off
the f6 knight or maybe even to e4 in
some lines
the problem is though so with black
getting a free hand on the queen side
black's next intended move is a4
and after knight f2 a4
cairo is forced to go to c1
another bad square for the night white's
pieces are just not looking good black's
queen side
is very spacious now so the best move
for white here after a5
is actually to go bishop e3 in order
after a4 to play knight t4
and keep white's pieces more active
after knight f2 though a4 not only is
white forced to play knight c1
but after knight d4 suddenly c2 is
hanging
and white's forced to play queen d1
so this is kind of an example of the
coiled spring you can see
right in this position black's position
is all on his own side of the board
not really making any threats against
white yet but in just a few moves
he suddenly moved three pieces to the
fifth rank and forced
several of white's pieces right back to
the first two ranks
so black's just kind of gotten this
flurry of activity very quickly
and now here depot makes one of those
key decisions for every sicilian player
deciding when to strike in the center
with one of these two pawns and he
decides correctly
he plays d5 here
generally speaking if you can get a pawn
if you can advance one of these pawns
under good circumstances
usually black is doing very well
so after e5 the question is how to
follow up
and nepo correctly plays this nice move
knight e4
and you can already see if white can't
pull something off here you can already
see how intimidating black's position is
especially compared to just a few moves
ago
the point is if white wants to do
something about this knight the only way
is to take on e4
but after black recaptures
we get these trades and black can
actually take on c2
and this is kind of the key moments
right for the moment
black's gotten more space black has
better minor pieces
but at the same time black's not castled
yet and black's knight on c2 is a little
awkward
so this would be the moment for white to
make something of this reach that black
did to try and punish it
however if white tries something like b3
to play rook c4 or if knight a3 to take
on b4
right this concretely would be the way
to try and punish black
but nepal read this out well black can
play queen c6
immediately targeting this rook
and if rook c4 black has time for bishop
c5 check
and knight a3 and funnily enough this
rook is actually trapped on c4
i mean don't get me wrong all this is
very tricky these are not positions you
should play without careful
thought but concretely nepo has read
everything out correctly
the blood of positional factors favor
black as long as you can stabilize the
position
and if he does this accurately if for
instance black by mistake goes castling
castle's here you know again after rook
c4 attending bishop c5 check in knight
a3
suddenly white goes king h1
now rook c4 is a huge threat and when
black plays knight a3
as is forced white can take on b4
so black has to play very accurately
this would actually give up the b4 pawn
because this rook c4 threat is so strong
but after the correct queen c6
everything works out for black and white
is actually in a lot of trouble because
this bishop is not as good
white's position is a little weak with
how advanced these pawns are and black's
rook can jump can jump to the open vials
so concretely this knight takes e4 line
which is kind of the critical line if
white wants to respond to this
works out for black and because of that
nakamura actually plays knight e2 and if
white has to play this it's just a very
good sign
so nepo declines the trade with knight
f5
and after king h1 goes queen b6
and you can see i mean it's kind of a
it's a crazy transformation right if you
look at white's pieces here
they're all stepping all over each
other's toes they're in this tiny box
and if you compare that to this position
where white's got this
pretty pretty strong arrangement of
pieces everything aside from maybe this
bishop which would like to be on e3
i mean here the rooks are ideal this
bishop's ready to attack these knights
get
can jump in soon
but this is where the this is what i
mean by coiled spring
everything just gets pushed back and
black just launches their position
forwards these pawns move forward these
knights take these great squares
and already white is in a world of
trouble here right after again what
looks like some pretty innocuous errors
it's not like material was blundered
it's not like white's position has been
shattered
but all the same now black has all the
activity black has better central
control
and better minor pieces as well
so white goes king h1 to avoid these
pins
queen h6 anyway after
if what if white takes here after bishop
c4
and even e3 followed by queen c6 looks
devastating
right the potential for this bishop is
very very high on these lines
it's won a lot of games in the timing
off
but instead kicaru goes knight h3 to
keep this diagonal more closed
i mean even simply taking on d2 would
give black a great position
better minor pieces better space but
nepo finds a very nice resource here
he goes bishop h4
and this move more than any really
highlights the poor state of white's
pieces
because this rook is trapped right it
can't move a single square in any
direction because there are white pieces
in the way
but if y goes g3
then black simply takes on d2
goes d4 check again thanks to this
knight
thanks to all white's poorly placed
pieces white has not a single good block
on this diagonal
because all white pieces are poorly
situated if white tonight were on f2
if this now we're out of the way or on
f3 where it would like to be y could
cover this diagonal just fine
but white doesn't have a single way to
manage here and after king g1
simply queen c6 is devastating
with crushing threats
but the only the only move for white at
this point is bishop b5 giving up the
bishop to pull the queen off the
diagonal
but white doesn't even have time to take
because the queen just comes back to c6
or to d5
and this basically ends the game
and because of this because white can't
afford to let this diagonal be opened
this means white can't afford to play g3
here
and it actually means black just wins
the exchange
you know already white is completely
lost after again what seemed like some
pretty innocuous moves
just a couple passive moves with the
knight it really doesn't take much
and that's why nepo has these wins as
black because he's glad he's happy to
play
and do these kinds of fish tour of
course black can mess up too right we're
seeing
we're seeing a master class from black
here but the time in off is very
double-edged
you know black can easily run up run
into big trouble on the king side as
well
but very good play by nepo and white has
fallen apart again surprisingly quickly
this is move 20
and his opponent is one of the best
players in the world
bishop c1 and now he just takes the
exchange white has
more space but still is cramped i
wouldn't say white has more space
anymore
he absolutely did when the pawns were on
e4 and d6 but blacks claimed a big chunk
of the center
black controls all these squares and
black controls the entire queen side now
white's pieces are all in the first two
ranks
light once have more space but once this
coiled spring like i said just
stretches out and takes the center and
the queen side white doesn't have much
and here white's position is just
terrible i mean white staved off an
immediate disaster by giving up the
exchange
but of course black has material and
compensation here
and it doesn't take long for an upper to
convert after knight g3 simply goes b3
forcing open some files on the queen
side for the rooks
takes takes
and there's really just nothing white
can do here the karo goes for some kind
of counter play with knight g5
but nepo is up to the task takes on g3
takes on c2
and now the rooks are just if white
takes the pawn the rooks just come into
the game
instead hikaru goes for f5 looking for
play
but after it takes takes he actually
just resigned on the spot he didn't even
wait for black to make a move
he said black has the exchange and
compensation here the easiest win for
black is just rook a1
when in addition to all his other
problems white faces serious issues here
knight takes g3 is a threat and after
bishop takes c2 black takes the c file
and will win a bishop so in addition to
the extra exchange white's position is
falling apart
and here nakamura resigned
and because of this win after drawing
the first mini match
nepal only needed a half point more to
win the second one he only needed a draw
in the last two games to take the win
in the quarter-final he duly got the
draw in the next game
and in large part thanks to this win
eliminated nakamura
so that win set up where we're currently
at in the tournament
that wouldn't set up his semi-final
match against none other than magnus
carlson
like world number one it's a very strong
opponent
and so this game this is nepo's game
against magnus from today from their
first semi-final match
they had started off with two draws
and in this game unlike the first two
games we looked at carlson opens with d4
knight f6 c4 e6 crosman goes for knight
f3
nepo goes for a queen scan but declined
and after the main move knight c3
he once again goes for a sharper line
the classical qgd is bishop e7
the regozin is bishop b4
semi-slav is c6 all of these are
perfectly dependable openings
but nepo goes for something much sharper
he goes he takes on c4
like i said spoilers
and when he takes on c4 white makes the
most common and most natural move i
would say e4 taking the center
there's a few more moves for black here
there's a lot of there's a lot of
options for both sides
but nepo goes for a very sharp middle
game very sharp line which is
with b5
not the most common move here as we're
going to see
recovering this pawn the pawn that
lights gambited on c4
takes some time
like magnus goes for the main line which
is e5 knight d5
knight b5 and knight b6
so white's recovered the pawn on b5
but at the same time black has a very
nice outpost on d5
this advanced spawn on c4 which really
restricts white's development
but at the same time can potentially be
very weak right it would not take much
for white to simply win this pawn and be
up upon
so this middle game is very tricky and
we've seen in past tournaments too it's
very easy to lose it with either side
it's actually it's not the first time
carlson has lost
in this variation with white
very tricky positions so both sides
develop logically bishop e2 knight c6
and here carlson makes the first unusual
move
the most common move here is just bishop
e3 again completing development
instead though carlson plays this less
common move queen d2
and bishop b3 was the movie it favored
before
this move looks a bit unusual but it
aims to get the rook out quickly
it gives potential to move to g5 it
supports g5
and it also offers potentially this
square queen a5 which just will see as
an idea later
so again it looks kind of funny blocking
your own bishop but the queen has a lot
of ideas
from this d2 square both sides continue
development
bishop up rook d1
and again all of this is pretty standard
this is a pretty standard setup for
black
aside from this less common queen d2
these are very standard for white
with this move black has ideas of this
typical tactic
discovering an attack on this knight
with something like knight e5
white goes to c3 and black goes to b4
and so very thematically black is aiming
to use this d5 outpost
and likewise because this bond is on c4
and not say b6
black has some weak squares on the queen
side
and magnus aims to use those as well c5
is a very desirable landing spot for a
knight
a5 is a very natural square for white's
queen
all right black's queen black's queen
side has a lot of space but it's not
stable
so this isn't as sharp it's not as
tactical as the timing off
but it's positionally and strategically
very risky for both sides
clean up can you cover carlson versus
nakamura in the last game of prelims
i think that game has i think you can
cover the game analysis of that on your
own
q1 yeah not a very long game that game
pretty quick draw
so rookie one potentially covering this
knight maybe enabling this bishop to
come here
queenside castles so once again
actually yeah so once again we see
opposite side castling
just like the geary game the queen side
looks a little risky
but at the same time black can advance
pretty quickly on the king side
so this position is very double-edged
so bishop f1
and nepo goes for an idea here which is
very typical
but also very risky nepo plays f5
aiming for a quick kingside expansion
aiming to generate quick threats here
and actually if you've ever played the
queen's gambit accepted
these lines with e4 knight f6 that reach
this structure
this idea is very common there as well
so it takes takes and this is the idea
black opens the g file black has some
good square control with these pawns
the flip side though right black's pawns
are kind of strewn all over the board
this e6 bond in particular can be weak
now
and objectively this position i would
say should be good for white
it's very difficult to play correctly as
we're going to see
you know even magnus carlsen struggled
to do so but objectively
white has a lot of good squares to use
some more measured king side play
perhaps even h6 g5 and pushing this way
it's probably more technically correct
but especially in rapid something like
this is not easy to deal with
so now magnus could go queen a5 looking
at knight c5
but instead decides to go queen e2
basically trying to target this newfound
weakness on e6
and potentially the spawn on c4 right
black does have a lot of targets in this
position
to balance out all the open lines
he ate and he takes the g file
so both sides are putting their pieces
on good squares
and f5 so this was a key moment in the
game
magnus plays g3 to activate this bishop
and contest this diagonal
and he doesn't it might it might feel a
little weakening to play g3 and it is
but you don't want to leave the bishop
here permanently
and this bishop can be very strong as
we're going to see
while this move is risky it was actually
correct judgment by magnus
after f5 he takes on d6 which is also
very strong
and this key moment was white's chance
to get a key white chance
to get a good position in this position
magnus should actually play fearlessly
and take on e6
and at first i mean again this looks
suicidal because the bishop's not on g2
yet and this diagonal is very
weak but the whole point is that when
nepal moves this knight knight c7 or
knight f4
white has this very nice move d5
and suddenly black's queen is hanging as
well as whites a queen trait is no good
for black here with this pawn structure
and white's bishop pair
the cleanest game is not what black
wants
and after black takes white's gonna have
one more crucial move
to reinforce this diagonal
white can play queen e2 with a very good
position
but the ever fearless computer is
actually even greedier it simply wants
to take this pawn
and it says that as dangerous as this
lineup looks there's no way for you to
use it quickly enough
an extremely decision extremely
difficult decision to make especially in
rapid
but this queen takes e6 and d5 right
this kind of very concrete play is
forced
to try and punish something like this
instead carlson plays more strategically
and less concretely
again it's very difficult to read things
like this out in classical much less
rapid he plays bishop g2 instead
all right covering this diagonal
covering the weak point but this means
black gets to keep the e6 pawn
and suddenly black has very strong
central control and very good light
square control with these pawns
and now the game again takes the game is
much more double-edged
white does have the bishop pair but this
bishop
is firing on pretty useless lines at the
moment and this knight on d5 is very
strong
at least it was more interesting than a
berlin draw absolutely yeah one thing
with these openings like i said the
positions you get tend to be very uneven
and very volatile the price of a mistake
from either side of these lines
is very very high as we're going to see
nepo activates his queen
brings the queen to b3
and here carlson slips
carlson plays bishop c3 by covering all
black's potential threats on the queen
side
black doesn't want to take because it
would open up his own king
but here he misses a very nice idea by
nepo
and this is the kind of right i said
very costly mistake that can come up in
these lines
knight f4 is that game of thrones on my
shelf
yes it is yep series of ice and fire
yeah knight f4 and now suddenly as soon
as the bishop abandons this square
nepal goes for the sacrifice and the
follow-up is rook g4
and suddenly this rook that was staring
at a rock-solid pawn
suddenly is creating very severe threats
to white's king
if knight f3 then rook g8 and white just
has no defense
too much firepower on the king side
and otherwise black's simply going to
take this knight which recovers the
material
and leaves white in a very tricky
situation on the king side
so magnus goes h3 right before black and
double rooks he's forcing the rook off
the g
file trades bishops and queen f3
and king a6 so black's king is still a
little shaky right there's never going
to be a proper
a proper pawn shield for this king but
on a6 there's not a good way for white
to bring threats to it just now
and in this position carlson makes the
fatal mistake
so strategically there's a lot of
undesirable factors to white's position
right this bishop is pretty bad white's
pawns now are actually the weaker ones
unlike most of the game
and of course white's king has opened up
that said
black's king is shaky and black also has
some weaknesses as well
so there is still there's three results
to play for there's all kinds of play to
go for in this game for away
and the best move is actually just
something like king h2
securing the king side potentially
aiming to use a rook here
you can see it wouldn't take much for
black's king to run into serious trouble
too
in this position so just something like
this
stabilizing the position again preparing
to activate his pieces was the way to go
but carlson goes for direct play maybe
overestimating the strategic danger of
his position or maybe he missed nepo's
reply
but he plays d5 and the idea is
when white take when black takes back
with the knight he sacrifices the
exchange
all right so he's taken away the best
defender of black's king this does leave
the king very open
and this works very well against
everything black can play
except for one line and
nepo is up to the task right so this
rook's under attack and queen c6 is a
threat
nepo solves the first threat with track
with rook g6
king comes to f1 and now nepo plays the
nice move queen b5
so he solves both the threats this queen
on b5 is very nicely placed
covering all the problems squares and
for and threatening a queen trade
and this actually beats back white's
initiative against the weak king
white simply lacks the firepower
to target this king properly right white
needs some more open lines
perhaps the light squared bishop as it
turns out
there's just no good square for this
queen to go to
if white goes to say f3 or to a8
black has this nice move queen b7
and because white's king's side is shaky
queen h1 can't be allowed or black gets
a monstrously strong attack
so this move forces a trait of queens
so the temporary initiative that white
gets by opening up black's king
concretely gets beaten back by this nice
move by nepo
so instead magnus agrees to trade queens
just says okay well i'll activate my
rook
while i do it but this does leave
him down the exchange and while black's
pawns are weak
this is nowhere near adequate
compensation for the exchange and upon
nepal has grabbed
so now it's a matter of conversion and
once again that was up to the task
white has some weak pawns as well
magnus goes for his own play but it's
just too much of a deficit
d6 this would get the pawn back
without a rook on the board these kinds
of end games tend to be completely
hopeless
black puts the pawns on light squares
the king walks in on the light squares
black could even just sack the exchange
on b2 and promote the c pawn for
instance
and without a rook all black has to do
again is use the light spurs and white
has no play at all
in this kind of position so magnus
realizes if he wants to play on he can't
afford to trade rooks
goes bishop e4 but now again now he's
just too far behind
king up rook d3 and nepo just starts
advancing the pawn
d4 can't be stopped
now b2 is dropping and here magnus
resigned
now this was the one decisive game of
their first mini match
excellent performance by nepo and it
means that tomorrow all he needs to do
is draw a second match
to reach the final and eliminate magnus
from the tournament
so we will see what happens perhaps some
games for me to cover next week
again three great performances by nepo
is winning with black has been ins was
crucial for both his qualifier
advancement and for both of his match
wins thus far
and again you can see just how how
aggressive how
sharply he's willing to play as black
and how much it rewards good play
when he plays well that's all i have
i hope you enjoyed the games if you have
any questions then feel free to ask them
and like i said there was there were he
had three other black ones in the
qualifiers in particular
i'd note the one against so it was a
very sharp very long actually double
edged game where he kept creating
problems
and what a position that you would not
expect to win from black again
playing very well against so highly
recommend looking at that game
i didn't include it today for time
reasons
but it's a great game
right well thank you all for watching i
hope you enjoyed it